yeah yeah to her natural mode Marin
ruggieri adorably announcements of
Sultan Qaboos his death came on state TV
the man who ruled Oman for 50 years had
been unwell for a number of years three
days of national mourning are now
underway in Amman and a number of
regional countries his funeral has
already been held in the capital Muscat
[Music]
and just hours after the announcement of
his death his family had already chosen
his successor - burnt article aside
Sultan Qaboos his cousin in true Imani
form his swearing in as the new Sultan
was a smooth and quick transition our
side has already served as culture
minister and was made in charge of the
country's 2040 vision development
programme we will remain guided by the
late Sultan's wisdom and will preserve
and embark on the achievements he made
this is what were adamant to do to
follow in his footsteps
with respect to international relations
we will follow the same course and
embrace foreign policies based on
peaceful coexistence the Sultana Zaman
spare amount decision-maker and also
holds the positions of prime minister
supreme commander of the Armed Forces
Minister of Defense finance and foreign
affairs he was holding a very important
position about heritage which has to
deal with the identity of a man as a
country and maintaining the the unity
and in the culture as with the Ferdinand
I which is in many context that's very
important also being secretary of
foreign affairs ministry that's also an
important because he was the person he
knows exactly what are the files the
country are dealing with sahibu Jalal
assault on Haytham bint arc Bentham
water the Omani flag will be flown at
half-mast to the 40-day Islamic period
of mourning this transition is a crucial
moment for the country
Semih had to shave a mohammed el khalili
with many waiting to see if Haytham
aside will continue cabooses legacy as a
negotiator and peacemaker in a volatile
region Sarah Hyde at al Jazeera